trump did a good job at exposing this
he continues to do a good job at
exposing this
that's why they hate trump but they
don't just hate trump
that is the biggest lie of the trump era
it's a bigger lie than the russia hoax
or the ukraine hoax or what any of those
things
the biggest lie of the trump era is that
the the left has some special hatred for
donald trump
they'll actually kind of like donald
trump remember donald trump was
in their clubs and in their parties for
decades
he was hollywood royalty a top network
tv star
hillary clinton and bill clinton came to
his wedding
good friends with oprah he was totally
in it
he was in rap songs all the time then he
comes out and he runs as a republican
and they say he's literally hitler
because they it's not just about him
they hate you
it's you it's not him it was the best
moment of his 2020 campaign
it was when he tweeted out that picture
and he said they're not coming for me
they're coming for you and i happen to
be in the way
it's not they don't think he's a nazi
they think you're a nazi they don't
think he's a racist they think you're a
racist
they don't think he's going to destroy
the country and he should be in prison
they think you're going to destroy the
country
and probably you should be in prison too
they have talked about these enemy lists
they've talked about
the truth and reconciliation commissions
re-education
they call you deplorable they call you
irredeemable they call you bitter
clingers that was obama's term
or obama's concept rather you had an
expert one of these geniuses on msnbc
comes out and mentioned that the next
guy is going to be just as bad as trump
he might talk a little better he might
sound a little better
but the gop wants another literally
hitler in 2024.
they are not going to be muted we're
going to hear them loudly
uh express that hypocrisy and act on
that hypocrisy
going forward because all they're
looking for now is a slightly more
civilized donald trump
that's why they think things are still
going fine for the party because they
look at the house results they look at
the senate results and say
we're doing fine if we can just get a
donald trump who's not quite so
not quite such a thug not quite so imp
unpalatable to so many people we can
find a more another white grievance
racist
sexist all of those things we find
another candidate like that but one who
doesn't have quite the rough edges
will be in shape that's what the
republican party is heading for uh
and that what their goal is as they head
towards 2024.
that's that's what they're going for
guaranteed no question
and you have this is uh i don't even
know this guy's name nor do i
particularly care to
he's on msnbc with the msnbc host and
with
tim miller who's an ex-republican he was
jeb bush's spokesman
one of the most vile slanderers
in politics right i mean absolutely you
know everybody who
disagrees with him anybody who disagrees
with the liberal left is a nazi and a
white supremacist
you hear this from ex-republicans it's
not just the radical left
it's guys who worked for jeb bush for
goodness sakes
this this sort of thing is going to amp
up and i think we're all going to
we're all going to feel a little if we
don't already feel some sympathy or
or empathy for president trump we
certainly will in 2024 when we find out
this wasn't about him
at all and we need to oppose this we
need to fight back against this
not just in this very narrow way of
shrinking
parts of the government or lowering
taxes or something like that
it's a whole blob it's a whole sort of
conspiracy it's not a conspiracy in the
sense that it's not even really
conscious
it's not like three men in a
smoke-filled room saying here's how
we're going to plot to
destroy the deplorable irredeemable
patriotic americans
it's just this whole edifice which
comprises
the universities certainly the media
obviously hollywood sure
even the scientific establishment which
is now saying that men can become women
based on nothing other than some fattish
ideology
that sort of thing
we have to push back against the whole
edifice
and if we don't do that it's going to
gobble us right up
even there's biden's campaign manager
who's probably going to be his deputy
chief of staff
even she she is her job is to go out
there and sell
joe biden's fake unity healing message
that he's now pretending
to be pushing joe biden a very divisive
figure
who said that mitt romney wanted to
re-enslave black people in america
joe biden who just lies i mean he's told
really awful lies in his life now he's
saying we need unity and healing and his
campaign manager
jen o'malley dylan says uh
yeah i want to work with republicans i'm
not saying they're not a bunch of
efforts
you know mitch mcconnell's terrible but
from start to finish
biden set out with this idea that unity
was possible that together we're
stronger
that we as a country need healing and
our politics needs that too
yeah yeah efforts yeah you're gonna heal
oh we're going to make you
heal you're going to heal whether you
like it or not
not exactly practicing what she preaches
they never do that though you'd always
see this
in on social media or people get letters
about this or even people on tv they say
trump is literally hitler he's
a nazi he's awful we need 70 million
nazis in this country
we need to beat them just like we beat
hitler antifa is good i hope antifa
punches all these guys in the face
because love trumps hate huh
hold on it's love trying yeah i love
trump's hate
and the in order to for love to trump
hate we need to kill
all the hateful people i think you've
got a
flaw somewhere in your logic
[Music]
[Music]